[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu sein rief welt
heute gibt es mal eine etwas andere
pizza und zwar gibt es heute eine
kreuzung auf der italienischen pizza und
dem türkischen lahmacun lammert und
kennt ihr vielleicht das sind diese ganz
ganz dünnen man sagt auch türkische
pizza dazu aber eigentlich eine pizza
nichts zu tun
jedenfalls werde ich heute wirklich eine
türkische pizza draus machen dafür mache
ich jetzt erstmal einen hefeteig ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten dafür nehme
ich für 700 gramm dinkelmehl 200 gramm
hartweizengrieß einen halben würfel hefe
30 gramm zuckerrübensirup 500 gramm
warmes wasser zwei teelöffel salz etwas
pfeffer und sechs esslöffel olivenöl
ich nehme jetzt zuerst mal die hefe
statt einem halben würfel hefe könnt ihr
auch ein päckchen trockenhefe nehmen und
ihr könnt den hefeteig also den
pizzateig wirklich super vorbereiten
auch gerne einen tag vorher schauen oder
zwei tage vorher
und dann im kühlschrank lagern und dann
nehmt ihr aber auch die hälfte der hefe
also wenn ihr denn jetzt wirklich über
ein tag oder zwei tage im kühlschrank
lagern wohl einfach nochmal die hierfür
menge reduzieren
ich gebe jetzt hier noch den
zuckerrübensirup dazu
statt zuckerrübensirup könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch zucker benutzen einfach
ein bisschen aber der serie bringt zum
einen eine dunkle farbe mit rein und so
ein bisschen so einem einzigen geschmack
es gebe ich hier das wasser dazu einfach
kurz berühren damit sich die hefe
auflöst ihr könnt hilfe übrigens immer
einfrieren
also ich habe auch immer eigentlich ein
ganz gutes fahrrad da immer auch was im
gefrierschrank und wenn ich dir dann
brauche nämlich sie einfach rauslassen
bei raumtemperatur auftaucht oder im
kühlschrank am abend vorher und dann
habt ihr immer für ihre hilfe da die
findet nämlich etwas besser als
trockenhefe ok und jetzt kommen einfach
alle anderen zutaten rein
ihr könnt den teig hoops natürlich auch
mit der hand verkneten
so habe ich aber beide hände frei
hartweizengrieß nehme ich jetzt auch
noch mit rein einfach für eine schöne
struktur zu den salzmann mit rein und
pfeffer für den geschmack
am schluss noch das öl und dann kann
dateien 5 bis 10 minuten zu einem
richtig schönen und geschmeidigen teig
verknetet werden
er sieht jetzt perfekt aus ich habe
jetzt auch schon mit hitze geknetet
einfach die maschine auf 34 grad
eingestellt
so ist er nämlich schon mal warm und
kann auch gleich schön aufgehen
ich nehme jetzt kurz raus und dann kurz
zu einer kugel formen und er hat auch
einfach schon mal eine ganz andere
haptik also normale hefeteig mit nur
mehr das so ein bisschen gruber und das
passt später wirklich perfekt zu der
türkische pizza jetzt fertig einfach
schüssel ein bisschen von dieser teig
nicht anklebt wertet den teig auch mit
dem spray
so trocknet die oberfläche nicht aus und
kann ihn jetzt abgedeckt von eine halbe
stunde bis stunde aufgehen lassen müssen
sich schön verdoppelt hat und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich auch schon mal die
füllung vorbereiten ist könnt ihr auch
am tag vorher schon machen gerne und
dann habt ihr alles bereit und könnte
dann wenn ihr essen möchte einfach nur
noch alles zubereiten
normalerweise würde ich infiziert darin
aufgehen lassen aber ich brauche die
maschine jetzt für mein hackfleisch also
was ist denn uns doch im ofen aufgehen
man kann hier weiterarbeiten wie
hackfleisch masse brauche ich 700 gramm
hackfleisch hier wird sich ihr rinder
hackfleisch 2 zwiebeln 2 knoblauchzehen
etwas olivenöl paprika mark wasser und
hier noch die gewürze salz pfeffer und
kreuzkümmel wenn ihr so richtig die
pizza türkisch teil machen wollt finde
ich solltet ihr das hackfleisch halb
halb mission das heißt lamm und rind so
habt ihr so den richtigen geschmack ich
hatte jetzt leider kein star habe jetzt
deswegen nur rinder hackfleisch aber
alles gut ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen
olivenöl geht es hier in meine pfanne
und kann's erhitzen und da kann ich dann
das hackfleisch gleich schon mal
portionsweise anbraten und in der
zwischenzeit hier schon mal die zwiebel
und knoblauchzehen fein schneiden
und ich mache das jetzt hier getrennt
von der soße
denn so habe ich die möglichkeit einmal
die hackfleisch maße zu machen dann die
tomatensoße extra zu machen und dann
kann man es eben wenn man möchte auch
vegan sogar zubereiten eben ohne diese
hackfleisch masse und nimmt dann statt
hackfleisch einfach etwas gemüse pilze
zum beispiel oder zucchini alles ganz
fein hacken und schön scharf anbraten
und dann habe ich hier auch was für
volkan und dennis
[Musik]
es ist einfach in kleinen portionen
anbraten
[Musik]
also wenn ihr eine kleine panne habe
dann den mehreren fraktionen bei mir
passt jetzt auch die ganze nation ist
einfach damit das hackfleisch nicht
kocht sondern wirklich schön
angebrachten werden
ansonsten fühlt die pfanne zu schnell ab
und es könnte dann eher so vor sich hin
du musst einfach schön krümelig anbraten
ich gebe dann doch noch ein bisschen öl
dazu
jetzt ist hier stellen krümelig
angebraten und jetzt kann ich die
zwiebel und knoblauch würfel dazu geben
[Musik]
jetzt schön mit anbraten das restliche
öl auch dazu geben und ich habe jetzt
hier eine halbe zwiebel auszurufen für
die tomatensoße weil es einfach zwei
große zwiebel waren sehr schön mit
anschwitzen
so bekommt ihr einfach wirklich richtig
schöne röstaromen mit ins gericht
es gibt jetzt aber kürzung deckel drauf
das einfach die knoblauch und zwiebeln
glasig werden sollte etwa zwei bis drei
minuten
[Musik]
perfekt hier kann ich jetzt aus paprika
markt dazu geben uns passt geschmacklich
wirklich super weil es einfach total
würzig und herzhaft schmeckt wenn ihr
das nicht da hat können sich aber auch
tomatenmark nehmen und dann einfach mit
etwas paprikapulver nachwürzen
dann lasse ich es jetzt mit dem wasser
ab so lösen sich jetzt auch alle
bestandteile am boden jetzt einfach nur
noch mit salz und pfeffer würzen
kreuzkümmel dazu wenn ich jetzt lahm
noch da hätte hätte ich noch ein
lorbeerblatt mit reingeschmissen einfach
so für den geschmack und dann muss die
hackfleisch füllung schon mal fertig und
ich mache gleich noch die tomatensoße
deckel traum und herr tauss für die
tomatensoße nämlich einen esslöffel
olivenöl die halbe zwiebel etwas
tomatenmark und gestückelte tomaten aus
der dose
ich habe ich eine knoblauchzehe salz
getrocknete minze pfeffer und chili drei
grüne spitze afrika die sind nicht
scharf und etwas petersilie für die
tomatensoße kann ich jetzt auch das
olivenöl in einem kleinen topf erhitzen
und die zwiebelwürfel schon mal anbraten
da kommt auch gleich die knoblauchzehe
dazu
[Musik]
das ganze mit einer schönen glas
anbraten
und ich kann hier schon mal die spitz
paprika und auch die petersilie fein
schneiden
[Musik]
das innere einfach raus die ist das
kerngehäuse
so richtig schöne kleine würfelchen
schneiden
[Musik]
dann gebe ich hier jetzt das tomatenmark
kurz mit arm und dann direkt mit den
tomaten ablöschen
das könnte hier auch gleich die gewürze
dazugeben
[Musik]
und einfach die sauce aufkochen lassen
dann schneide ich jetzt aber die steht
weg die schmeiße ich aber nicht weg
sondern für sie ein und wenn ich dann
mal eine gemüsebrühe mache habe ich sie
einfach schon bereit die stadt jetzt
abheben das muss die restliche
petersilie einfach schön fein hacken
so ein bisschen was habe ich auch später
zum bestreuen
jetzt ist im prinzip alles vorbereitet
die paprika kommt jetzt mit rein
das bringt so diesem nach norden
geschmack mit rein auch petersilie
aber wie gesagt nicht alles den rest
beweisen wir auf dafür zum drüberstreuen
jetzt habe ich die soße fertig das
hackfleisch ist fertig warte jetzt
einfach nur noch bis der teig schön
aufgeht und dann können wir die pizza
gleich zubereiten und das könnte
wirklich alles super vorbereiten
den teig könnte vorbereiten hackfleisch
die soße auch gerne alles schon am
vortrag oder am vorabend und dann wenn
ihr essen möchte einfach frisch alles
zusammen setzen und dann habt ihr
wirklich ganz schnell und einfach ein
schönes abendessen oder ein schönes
iftar essen wenn ihr fastenbrechen macht
und haben am abend nicht so viel arbeit
also los gehts ich nehme jetzt ein
bisschen hartweizengrieß ich habe meine
bank matte ihr könnt auch mehr nehmen
aber hat bereits im griff hat einfach
ein bisschen mehr biss ihr könnt jetzt
entweder vier große machen oder zum
beispiel zwölf kleine oder auch 16
kleine pizzen ich mach jetzt 12 ich
nehme es einfach hier einen einteiler
dann habe ich nämlich schon 12 ansonsten
vierteln und dann nochmal jedes viertel
drittel
[Musik]
was ihr zu kugeln formen
ok ich denke ich jetzt immer schön ab
damit sie nicht trocknen und nehme jetzt
noch mal ein bisschen gries nehme ich
hier meine erste kugel jetzt können das
einfach mit der hand öffnen
wieso ein pizzateig oder in mein auto
starb die sind tatsächlich so klein dass
ich glaube ich mache das eine auswahl
statt
da passt meine hand gleich nicht rein
die hier schon geöffnet ich mache jetzt
erstmal nur zwei fertig damit ihr gleich
seht wie das alles funktioniert und
später mache ich für die meute alle
fertig ich nehme es ihr einfach mein
lochblech ihr könnt aber auch dass er
mixa blech nehmen
das hätte ich jetzt ganz leicht mit back
trance prey pizza stufe ist auch schon
an den backofen ansonsten nehmen wir
einfach unter hitze wenn es geht die
höchste einstellung 250 grad zum
beispiel damit die pizza schön von unten
cross wert und jetzt kann ich es ja auch
schon belegen mancher jetzt direkt hier
drauf und nachdem belegen auch wirklich
sofort backen ansonsten habt ihr nämlich
das problem gerade bei so einem
großflächigen blech darf der pizzateig
hinunter sinkt und er kriegt er die
pizza nicht mehr ab also wirklich
belegen und sofort im backofen rhein so
schön tomatensoße verteilen
die hackfleisch masse und wenn ihr wollt
könnt ihr noch pinienkerne drüberstreuen
die resten dann auch noch schön im
backofen perfekt und so kommt schon mal
einen backofen wie sich dann die anderen
machen
[Musik]
ich habe mich jetzt doch so was machst
du ja egal ist einfach petersen gestänge
ich habe mir jetzt doch dazu
entschlossen sechs große zu machen und
klar die ersten zwei kleinen theaters
aus dem rest mache ich jetzt auch vier
große beziehungsweise mittelgroße denn
es gefällt mir einfach optisch besser
und ich möchte dass er luftiger wird und
nicht ganz so dünn
deswegen habe ich jetzt noch dass er
myplace rettete kurz und da gibt es
nämlich schon richtig coolen tricks also
auch wieder hier erst mal mit etwas
hartweizengrieß für den crash boden dann
ein bisschen ausrollen
wenn die teig kugeln länger liegen dann
könnt ihr euch wirklich den ausbau starb
sparen dann ist der teig einfach
elastischer und ihr könnt ihn direkt mit
der hand öffnen und hier mache ist jetzt
nämlich so nur noch christian gries mit
aufs blech rüber und kann jetzt
praktisch durch eine drehbewegung den
teig einfach im blech öffnen form hier
nämlich immer gerne so einen kleinen
randhir und dann ganz normal belegen wie
vorhin eben auch
[Musik]
in seinem ipad können das jetzt nämlich
auch einfach zubereiten alles
vorbereiten und dann nach und nach
backen
da muss man nicht warten und nicht
sofort backen
[Musik]
meine testpersonen ist jetzt da ja ich
bin eine person die anderen sitzen sind
noch immer offen teilweise aber auch
schon fertig wird nämlich bei uns
gegessen
ihr könnt jetzt wie gesagt noch die
petersilie darüber streuen
in echt gespannt ich habe jetzt die
übrigens zubereitet und das kann nicht
echt besser zu bereiten bisschen liegen
lassen so kann der teig noch mal schön
luftig aufgehen und die die ich direkt
gebacken habe dies als flacher und
knuspriger böse sind wichtige pizza
lahmacun style nach morgens sei also
kein nachlassen sondern richtig so
wirklich italien trifft türkei natürlich
noch joghurt drei 100-prozentigen etwas
salz und die sich jetzt natürlich auch
wieder typisch türkisch mann ist nämlich
wie man gut zusammen und das ist richtig
cool menzel knobloch ja aber ich habe
genug einfach trat deswegen essen auch
gleich alle märz denn sonst haben wir
gleich keine freunde mehr pfeffer
brauche ich aber noch war ich dann ja
weil knoblauch hilft gegen alles das ist
bewiesen ist sorgt dafür dass er den
mindestabstand einhalten von 1,5 mio
hallo und jetzt kann ich das hier schon
zu schneiden
hast du alle geraten dürfen alle rein
jetzt probieren magst du erstmal ohne
joghurtbecher und genau das den
geschmack ich bin so der joghurt es für
falsch ich bin mal gespannt ich etwas
neues gemacht ob du das merkt am
pizzateig und ich habe nicht so viel
chili wo hatte können alle reinschauen
und ich habe nicht so viel chili wegen
der kinder wie kann man mit zwei
bisschen ganz echt ein stück pizza
aufwerfen die können schon mal tisch
gehen ja mit abstand eine den besten pc
hier ist nichts ohne sport wahnsinn
manche noch ein stück kommt joghurt und
wie gesagt ihr könnt einfach alles
wunderbar vorbereiten den pizzateig die
tomatensoße
das hackfleisch dann können das auch
noch schön vorbereiten und wirklich kurz
vorm essen alles im backofen schieben
und fertig und ich habe dazu noch warten
was die anderen essen gleich ob dieser
summe leute prägung ich habe dazu noch
einen gemischten salat gemacht mit
rotkohl mit karotten da steht hier auch
jeder darauf mit spinat drinnen machen
pizza abitibi gemacht die sich mit der
aula das wasser im mund zusammen
vielleicht die beste pizza dir jemals
gegessen und guten appetit auf sondern
das rezept gibt es natürlich in meiner
app wir nachlesen zum hoch und runter
rechnen und wir essen jetzt auch
[Musik]
michaela ich werde so lecker dass
probiert ist obwohl der kraft hallo
können wir am tisch essen
[Musik]